So first, our selective attention is when we're focusing on what the
professor's saying and ignoring when the room is cold or the person by us is
smacking. Your inattentional blindness is when you didn't notice that there was
a man outside doing interpretive dance and reciting a poem saying I love you
Tory, be mine, but everybody else in class noticed. Here, when you heard the
people behind you talking about your favorite band, this was a cocktail party
effect. Given you're focusing on the essay, here again, we have selective
attention. And finally, when you realize the girl you borrowed the pen from was
no longer sitting next to you and it was now a guy that was sleeping on his
desk. This was your change blindness.